هذه الاماكن المخصصه لتعليق قائمه
المترشحين للانتخابات التشريعيه باتت
جاهزه بمجرد انطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه
لاستقبال برامج المراهمين على اخذ مقاعد
في البرلمان القادم هي كما الفضاءات
العامه هيئه الانتخابات وضعت اخر لمسات
وفق الرزنامه المحدده سلفا الامر قد يبدو
عاديا الى هنا لكن خصوصيه هذا الاستحقاق
التشريعي وطابعه الاستثنائيه جعل السعيد
الى افشاله لا يترددون في انتاج كل السبل
ومنها تحريك الشارع والتوجه الى دوائر
خارجيه المعارضه التي بقيت تقريبا في ولا
السنه كامله وهي ويتجداد وتعمل وتقوم بكل
من شانه ان يسقط هذا المشروع الذي تجى
اليه رئيس قيس سعيد تبين فشلها وتبين ان
عاجزه من ان تحرك الشارع في تونس واعتقد
ان اهتمامات تونسيه بالفعل هي سياسيه ولكن
كذلك اقتصاديه ومعيشيه اسرع يحتضم اذا بين
مؤيد ورافض ومقاطع واخرين مطالبين
بالتاجيل الكل يبسط حججه واسبابه لكن
الشارع المنشغله بواقعه الاقتصادي صعب
والاجتماعيه المترديه له راي الاخر
في عهد العشريه السوداء لحقيقه ما بوجه
جديد
لتركيز الجمهوريه الجديده وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس